I have Nicol SP with reason TV and we
are at the International Student for
liberty conference of Washington DC and
we are talking to John Mackey he's the
co CEO and co-founder of Whole Foods and
the author co-author of conscious
capitalism liberating the heroic spirit
of business written with Raj Sisodia
John thanks for talking to us thanks for
having me on there okay this book is in
many ways a kind of summary statement of
principles that you've been working out
for years and continue to develop but
let's start by talking about what is
conscious capitalism in its most concise
definition well the most concise
definition is that it's free enterprise
capitalism done engaged in more
consciously right and and so this is I
mean people I mean it's not just
happening people are thinking about what
they're doing and you know and taking a
kind of responsibility for everything
that's going on yes
you talk in the book I mean there's a
pyramid with four parts in it you say
are the four tenets of conscious
capitalism higher purpose conscious
leadership conscious culture and
management and stakeholder integration
let's talk about those and then we'll go
to some specific examples but when you
say a business that is exhibiting or
practicing conscious capitalism has a
higher purpose what do you mean by that
I mean it has a purpose beyond just
making money
I think the critics of capitalism have
gotten in this very small box but it's
all about money
it's basically greedy and selfish and
exploitative and yet I haven't found it
to be that way I mean well I've known
hundreds of entrepreneurs and with very
few exceptions most of them did not
start their businesses primarily to make
money not that there's anything wrong
with making money wrote my body
I can't live unless it produces red
blood cells no red blood cells I'm a
dead man but that's not the purpose of
my life to produce red blood cells
similarly a business cannot exist and
less profitable it can't innovate it
can't evolve it can't meet competitive
challenges it can't even repair its
equipment once it's profitable so
profits necessary we're just as doctors
they're very well compensated in our
society but their purpose is not to make
money their purpose is to heal people so
you're saying that I mean a you know
just as a doctor if they could make more
money being a lawyer an Indian chief
they wouldn't switch to that most
entrepreneurs and most good businesses
most great businesses I mean you're you
you are not going to switch to something
that has a higher return on investment
simply because you could make more money
doing correct and it you write in the
book great companies have great purposes
you talk about the the purposes can vary
from being the good the true the
beautiful the heroic what is wholefoods
higher purpose we have several higher
purposes it's evolved over time I mean
when we started the business or higher
purpose was very simple it was basically
to sell healthy food to people earn a
living for ourselves and have fun now as
the businesses grown our purpose has
evolved along with it that usually when
I try to articulate one higher purpose I
say that part of our higher purpose is
to help heal America because we're now
69 percent overweight 36 percent obese
and 80 percent of what we spend on
health care or for lifestyle diseases
such as heart disease stroke diabetes
autoimmune diseases and cancer which
correlate very closely with diet and
lifestyle so by educating people about
the principle
healthy eating and selling them healthy
foods we think we're helping people to
avoid these diseases and live longer and
that's something that built up over time
because as you were saying that's not
what when you started this in Boston in
a kind of ramshackle storefront that's
not what you were thinking but it's
moved towards that yeah I mean just as
we grow as human beings over time our
own sense of who we are evolve so can a
business a sense of what it is and why
it exists evolve over time as well I
think as a business begins to pursue
higher purposes it it helps align all
these stakeholders together and it helps
the business to I think to be more
successful which is one of the reasons
we articulate why it's important that
business should seek its higher purpose
beyond making money and the group that
the good the true and the beautiful by
Plato I mean these are timeless ideals
business is fundamentally a human
activity that humans engage in why
shouldn't that also be in the pursuit of
the highest ideals humans have ever
articulated well and talking about
stakeholders that's one of the other
tenants of capitalism which is
stakeholder integration and I think this
is from people on the kind of
traditional or conventional free-market
of right or beside this is where
sometimes they think some of the things
you're saying sound dangerously
communistic stakeholders as opposed to
shareholders and you actually you right
you talk about stakeholders as the
essence of the company and that
stakeholders include shareholders but
you also talk about investors versus
speculators loyal trust and customers
inspired team members patient purposeful
investors collaborative innovative
suppliers flourishing welcoming
communities the environment as a
stakeholder talk a little bit about
stakeholders and you know what what what
is the nesting order of stakeholders as
as the essence of a conscious capitalist
color well I think one of the reasons
people libertarians and
maybe conservatives have a problem with
stakeholders is that they to a certain
extent distrust that this is just some
trick to screw the stockholders the
stockholders or they get paid last
customers get paid as soon as they
exchange with the business employees get
paid every couple of weeks
suppliers get paid every thirty days the
government gets paid whenever it wants
to
and only the stockholders get paid if
there's anything left over and that's
usually not that much and most
businesses so I think that distrust is
somewhat warranted but of course what we
mean by stakeholders is simply
recognizing that for a business to
flourish you have to create value for
all of those stakeholders and as simple
an example I like to use as a grocery
retailer is that our job as management
of Whole Foods is to find and hire the
very best people we can make sure
they're well trained in their jobs and
then help them to be happy help them to
flourish because we found when our team
members are happy they give better
service to our customers that helps the
customers to be happy that creates
loyalty commitment to our stores they
spread the word to their friends and the
business is successful that results in
happy investors so happy
team members results in happy customers
which results in happy investors you've
got suppliers that you're exchanging
with you voluntarily that create
competitive advantage so all of these
stakeholders are interdependent on one
another and the conscious business
recognizes that and so it consciously
creates value for all of them because
then you're managing the whole system
you're helping the whole system to
flourish and that helps the investors to
fly I mean in a lot of ways this is what
you're talking about in the shift from a
kind of industrial industrial
revolutionary style capitalism to a
conscious capitalism is that shift from
individual actors or firms to more of a
holistic model that we're in an
ecosystem they're both gained it's it's
not human beings are both individuals
and yet were members of communities some
of those are voluntary through common
interest or we join companies we join
those communities other were born into
our families our nation
are our tribes so to speak so I think I
think we need to recognize that we're
fundamentally individuals and were
members of communities and we shouldn't
sacrifice individuals for the
communities but neither should we ignore
the communities we need to we need to
have both flourish you know to talk
about stakeholders to I mean you you
talk about the outer circle of
stakeholders and at one point in the
book you talk about troubles or issues
that whole foods that for years has had
with unions and you specific now the
unions and government to a certain
degree of regulators are stakeholders in
that they they have something to say
about businesses whether or not they're
adding to it talk a little bit about
your example in in Madison Wisconsin
with a union where unions got into a
Whole Foods generally the stores are not
organized and you would argue that
they're not organized because the
workers don't want them there getting a
best deal that they could talk about the
Madison Wisconsin experience you detail
in the book and how that allowed you to
kind of think more about how to you know
how to improve your relationships with
the workers or team one of the important
things to understand a couple things to
understand one is that of course unions
often say that we prevent them from
unionizing which is a lie they're
legally protected employees can choose
union representation if they wish they
don't choose it then they should have
the right not to choose it
and in the case of Madison was this
happened back in the year 2002 an
isolated store kind of out there one
store Madison away from the regional
base in Chicago and we ended up with a
bad store team leader there and we
didn't really we weren't paying enough
attention to the declining morale survey
scores that we got so we could see in
hindsight that the morale was was
declining but the regional leadership
didn't do anything about it and and then
of course they've we had some organizers
hire in for the summer with the express
intent to organize the store and they
were successful it was a close vote
but the union was voted in and there
before we began to quote negotiate a
contract with them but no contract was
ever signed the union had made a lot of
promises that they were not able to
deliver on and what interesting had
happened was that it was such a wake-up
call for me personally and the company
as a whole it's like how could this
happen
how could we must not be doing as good a
job because in a way the union is a
competitor they compete for the hearts
and minds of your employees and if
people are fundamentally happy they're
not going to be a reason to select a
union representation that are unhappy
then selecting a union is a good proxy
indicator of that so we're what were
some of the things that you changed in
response to the Union making it in row
well one thing I did was I then began I
visited every store in the company over
over a year long period which was back
then was about 150 stores and I had
dialogue after dialogue up a dialogue
with our team members about how he could
make the company better
one of things I heard consistently was
our health insurance could be better our
health insurer could be better and
what's wrong with it
well we don't have complete coverage of
everybody and what people would talk
about their frustrations with and it
wasn't simple enough
and we basically changed our health
insurance plan to the system that we
have today with a high deductible plan
that covers all of our full-time workers
automatically and we put in a personal
wellness account or health savings
account we donated money to that they
could spend on their own and that plan
has been extremely very popular with our
team members now we could do that
everywhere except for Madison because we
were in negotiations there so the team
members at Madison will love that health
insurance plan but they weren't allowed
to have it until there was a contract
signed we improved our paid time off for
people increased our vacation benefit
plan and so we made these improvements
based on the tour
everywhere except for Madison meanwhile
the Union was not really able to deliver
on any of their promises we negotiated
with them in good faith but their their
demands were funding fundamentally
unreasonable did they go away and now is
Madison back in the hole wouldn't have
happening Nick was that the team members
themselves they're strict laws that
prevent management from getting involved
in any kind of decertification
unions can organize you but you can't
actually work to decertify a union once
they're in it had to be we couldn't help
them in any way when they would contact
us we want to get rid of this Union we
had to be silent so they figured it out
on their own
and they chose to decertify themselves
voluntarily about 12 months which is as
soon as you can do it they do certified
the Union 12 months after they put it in
I mean the activists had already left
then you're just left with team members
who are fundamentally Union wasn't doing
anything for in your discussion of
conscious leadership you talked about
the rise of feminine values and it
feminine is kind of in quotes there
because these are things that are
typically associated with feminine
values caring compassion cooperation
things like that what is gained by
thinking about the feminine values that
might be brought into play in a business
environment we need a different kind of
leadership to manage these organizations
in the 21st century if your leadership
is not very conscious you're not going
to have a very conscious company because
they will sabotage it they will be
threatened by it and they will just
basically shut it down
so my conscious leadership we generally
mean leaders with a higher degree of
emotional intelligence higher degree of
spiritual intelligence again this is
something where when you think of like
the conventional histories of titans of
business you don't think about Andrew
Carnegie's emotional intelligence or his
feminine values or you know john d
rockefeller different at different era
yeah and so you know when you're saying
you know we need different leadership
this is we don't need the person who is
issuing orders from on high and what how
does servant leadership playing well a
servant leader is someone if you think
about oftentimes the motivations in the
past why somebody would want to be a
leader they might have a strong lust for
power they basically like to boss people
around still attracts people in certain
governmental bureaucracies they
basically like to throw their weight
around and secondly they might be
attracted to it for the money so either
a sort of a military power or mercenary
well arguably the servant leader is more
made it motivated by purpose by serving
the organization by taking just like a
parent might want their children to
flourish and the parent serves their
children so in a conscious business a
conscious leader serves the organization
it helps the organization to reach its
highest potential it puts the good of
the organization first who are some
leaders you know that are out there now
or in the past that you think provide
good models of this type of servant
leadership herb Keller of Southwest
Airlines is a great example and and he's
fascinating because he's not to tell you
you know it's interesting you wouldn't
say ok well he's got a lot of feminine
values because he's an old style kind of
cigar-chomping or cigarette-smoking old
line businessman but in fact he created
a radically different way of doing a
flight the herb has an amaru Gris of
emotional intelligence and I would argue
spiritual intelligence well he's a
servant leader he may like to drink and
smoke but that doesn't mean you can do
ultimately with leadership it has to do
with your own personal
attitudes towards pleasure and health I
suppose you also talked about in
conscious leadership that the leaders of
an organization I mean they supply the
vision or they help develop the vision
and you know that you learn through
adversity and you talk about the the
conflicts they had in 2007 with the
Federal Trade Commission as well as the
Securities and Exchange Commission and
how did that help you I mean you you
talk a lot about how what you did as a
leader as you went and looked inward as
you were going through some difficulties
sometimes we get in situations in life
where we're under a lot of stress it's a
crisis and our skill set that we know
how to do is inadequate for the
situation the normal reaction for most
people would face with that is basically
some type of contraction try to go back
to some safe place or it won't be so
painful they won't be so afraid in my
experience you should do exactly the
opposite and under type of stress
instead of contracting backwards you
should open wider and at this point in
2007 you were merging with wild Iraq
that was being held up by the FTC and
then an SEC Commission investigation
which ended up finding you blameless the
FTC leaked out that I've been posting on
the internet and I've been doing it for
eight years under a screen name
which is like going to a Halloween party
and wearing a costume which is the
custom that you do at a Halloween party
and the custome do at a financial
bulletin boards take a screen name on
and out a 1400 post I did have a few
that were critical of Wild Oats although
be it almost a year before we actually
began to negotiate with wild lows and
the media jizz sensationalized that made
into a big deal the next thing I know I
was being investigated by the Securities
and Exchange Commission for perhaps I
was giving away inside information that
came to nothing and they ended up
dropping their lawsuit you were
accusations evident you were also I mean
that was in the media a lot
okay well Mackey's done at Whole Foods
this is problematic
defend myself and yet legally you were
not allowed to comment it's very painful
when you're being smeared and without
any opportunity to write the interviewed
like we're being right now or in any way
get your story out there so what are you
very difficult were you what did you do
I mean talk about what you discuss in
the book of like how you grew and then
how does that well you know how does
that affect the organization because is
it just you in a room somewhere doing
you know yogic breathing or how does it
grow out into the organization of course
as far as the organization was concerned
for almost a year I was doing little bit
talk to lawyers it was undoubtedly the
most unpleasant episode in my 34 year
career with the company and I assume in
a lot of ways one of the most
unproductive because if you're talking
to lawyers you're not totally you're not
solid no just just wasting time talking
to lawyers going over all these posts
that I had written in a spirit of play
to see what the hidden meanings of it
might be so that was very unpleasant I
mean I thought about quitting more than
once and I mean I did some stuff that I
mean I meditated more I've always been a
meditator and I did more and deeper
meditations I also did something that
I've done many times before as well but
had been several years I did something
called holotropic breathwork where
you're basically with a guide you're
basically just simply doing continuous
deep breathing and I can't really tell
you exactly why this happens I suspect
it has something to do with the extra
oxygen that you're bringing into your
system that activates certain parts of
your brain that generally or not and
can't access and close down to it
couldn't access except for perhaps
through some type of a hallucinogenic
drugs but the actual deep breathing
exercises
yo yoga breathing can do the same thing
pranayama with a guide enabled me to get
really deep into who I was what my
motives were what my purpose was and I
kind of reconnected with my purpose in
life what I was trying to do and also
how I needed to grow and evolve if I was
going to continue to stay in charge of
Whole Foods
it actually went through this process
where I was acting this dialogue I think
with my higher self asking whether I was
prepared to step up and it put these
conditions were you willing to do this
are you willing to do this you when we
can do this and I kept saying yes yes
and yes and then when that process was
over and I completely embraced what I
think is my higher purpose in life it
all cleared up just like that I mean the
sec dropped their investigation like a
week later but now that's not because I
mean it's it's not some kind of karmic
shout-out I have no idea but not it
worked out all I'm saying is whether
that's coincidental or caught and cause
alight who can say the world is a life
is a very bizarre thing I assure you
that there's many weird things happening
well now let's talk about the fourth
tenant which is conscious culture and
management and and leadership and
management are distinct in your
conception of things and talk about what
what's in a conscious capitalist firm
conscious culture what does that mean
and how is it different in your telling
than say you know when you talk to
people who work for IBM you know back in
the 50s and 60s there was a very
conscious culture I mean a very rigid
culture that everybody knew and
everybody participated in salesmen wore
blue navy blue suits and you know a
white shirt and a red tie brown shoes or
whatever brown shoes were not allowed
etc everything went through a chain of
command this and that so there's a lot
of businesses and the great kind of
post-war businesses AT&T GM
you know Xerox had a conscious culture
but you're talking about it in a
different way how how is it different
well what we mean by that is we need to
create cultures that really allow that
the employees of the organization to
fully flourish for them to be happy for
them to be able to self actualize
themselves reach their highest potential
they can the conscious business knows
that ultimately it's it's employee basis
it's it's if you have an engaged
employee base that's that's enthusiastic
and happy and and you're going to get a
lower turnover you're also going to get
more innovation more creativity so you
need to design cultures that really
allow the business to reach its highest
value how do you get it where it's just
workers or team members or you know
employees or you know the people that
you work with that you collaborate with
aren't like well you know what I don't
really want to be in the food business I
want to you know I want to start doing
something else and how do you how do you
give people enough space where they can
develop and actualize themselves but
where they just don't start going off in
different directions they do go off in
different directions I mean some people
you might say play with us at Whole
Foods for a year or two and then they go
off and become journalists or hitchhike
around the world or start their own
businesses but get a lot of young people
who don't necessarily know who they are
what their lives about yet I mean I'd
have very low turnover rates under 10%
voluntary turnover per year which for
retail is extremely low but you do talk
a lot about just you know part of the
kind of tenant of conscious culture
management does have to do with
decentralization and empowerment you're
actually in a way and again this is very
different than kind of old-style Brooke
you know heavily hierarchical
corporations where you let people make
decisions you not only tell them to make
decisions but you actually give them the
ability to act out on those one way to
think about what's happened Nick is that
the old management structure the
traditional management structure was
what metaphors did it have it had for
large-scale enterprise it had the
military which is very hierarchical
command and control it had the church
also very hierarchical command and
control and then is in the Industrial
Revolution
you had the metaphor of the factory in
the assembly line so basically the human
element was organized that way as well
and that they were all basically the
same I never treated this thing exactly
this system worked relatively well for a
while because it was you had economies
of scale to it you had people might have
been cogs in an industrial machine but
the machine itself was was was awesome
in terms of what had come before it
wrote but now as we get into the 21st
century and we're connected together
we're much better educated we've moved
up kind of Maslow's hierarchy of needs
people don't want to be cogs in the
machine anymore that's just not
dehumanized with this and they don't
even want to be cells in the body right
I mean it's that metaphor doesn't even
quite do just we don't know exactly what
it's like to be a cell and a buddy it
may not be you could argue that I've got
100 trillion cells they're all
voluntarily cooperating for mutual
benefit I know many of my disappoint me
on a regular basis I know it fortunately
you can get rid of this I hope well tuck
in you you go into an episode in your
hartford store in 2007 where you talk
about how you were faced with certain
issues and you know kind of building a
conscious culture and management helped
get
out of that talk a little bit about that
we lost power in his store and was in a
very busy time so it was a snowstorm was
coming or something like that so people
were rushing yeah and and then your
catch right we lost our cast we lost our
cash registers and went out so the the
store team leader was off that day and
so the associate store team leader was
there just made a decision it's like
okay this was right I think near
Christmas as well so that store team
leader just said until we get power back
online all the people when they got to
the registers we just let him take the
food for free we didn't make an
announcement that said yeah it's all
free but we didn't charge anybody
anything it was several thousand dollars
that they were basically gifted out to
our customers but I mean it wasn't their
fault right why should they be punished
and that they want to just get home to
their families and so we just thought
that was that associate store chain we
thought that was the right thing to do
for our customers and we teach the
customers the most important stakeholder
do whatever is necessary make the
customer happy was interesting thing
that happened that was absolutely the
right thing to do nobody ever
second-guess that decision but it had a
happy ending to it which is that it got
picked up by the media and the next
thing we know it's it's actually in the
media gets picked up around the country
and people see that as an example of
Christmas spirit so if the few thousand
dollars of free groceries we gave away
we're more than compensated for by the
tens of thousands of dollars hundreds of
thousands of dollars of goodwill and
free publicity and it does showcase I
mean I could see a lot of companies
where they would you know the person in
charge would be totally freaking out or
trying to get their boss on the line or
the boss to say like hey is this okay or
they be afraid they'll fire you know
what do you mean you gave the food away
and you you talk in the same chapter
about Nordstrom's apparently Nordstrom
has about the shortest employee
guidebook
what is their one directive to their
employees I think you have two
guidelines guideline number one is use
your best judgment in all situations and
guideline number two is see number one
right in a sense that's the ultimate
empowerment basically saying we trust
you take care of our customers do
whatever is necessary for the customer
and then how do you come back and
evaluate that because obviously there
are going to be times when employees
either through bad faith or good faith
you know just make bad decisions how do
you how do you come back and correct
problems well you if somebody makes a
bad decision you so to speak a teachable
moments you can use that example to
educate them but you don't want to
punish people for when they're taking
care of your customers you don't want to
punish people for that you're basically
sending the exact wrong message to the
organization you want to you basically
want to reward people for taking care of
your customers if they have a mistake in
judgment in a very non-public way you
might say we appreciate your intention
here but maybe next time in the future
you might want to do this instead you
know that conversation critical you do
you have a lot of discussion with your
board of directors or how long did it
take to get your board of directors to
fully both buy into your you know and I
realize it's a kind of feedback loop but
how long did it take to find the you
know major investors who were not
speculators who are not like okay what
are you doing for me next course or
different things we're talking about our
board you're talking about our
shareholders which one you want to talk
about let's talk about the board first
and then share org has been evolving for
decades
are we been a public company for 21 21
years now so for the longest time as the
entrepreneur I used to just ignore the
board it's like okay we got to have a
board
so what but over time perhaps because
almost got fired back in the year 2000 I
began to wake up to the reality that got
to take the board very seriously and
it's not just because they could fire
you but also because they were a
storehouse of information and knowledge
well they weren't aligned with it back
then they weren't necessarily aligned
with the values of Whole Foods Market
they were just more traditional on a lot
of the court a lot had a lot of
traditional corporate values so I'm very
careful then of educating our board and
also in where as management can't choose
the board that's done by the board
itself and voted by the shareholders
we could we would vet them and we'd give
our feedback about we like her better
than him these are the reasons why and
generally our opinions would be taken
into consideration so I do think you
need your board aligned with your higher
purpose and Whole Foods is board it
currently is and then shareholders as
well I mean are they are they a
different breed of investor you know
where they're willing to say okay you
know what we've had a couple of bad
quarters but well we get where you're
going that's a little trickier we are
public companies so we have thousands
and thousands of shareholders and they
could be all over the map in terms of
what they want like our customers are
very diverse as well but what we've done
is we've cultivated long term investors
that they're you can recognize after a
while that some institutional investors
really do mean it when they say we buy
and hold for at least five years and
those are the investors that we really
want to invest in our company those who
are basically day traders or or in or
out we don't encourage them to be
industrious under stock and the best way
to do that is to just be transparent
about what you're doing here's who we
are here's what we're going to do we're
always going to make decisions that are
in the best long-term interest of our
shareholders even if it hurts us in the
short run and the speculators may stray
away stay away from us as a result of
that so they don't always do that as our
stock has traded up they start to pile
in and you've been able to maintain a
very strong position even through a
pretty rotten economy for a for a long
time do you attribute that to a kind of
long-range planning mentality I
attribute it to you know we're not
really long-range planners but I do
attribute the loyalty that a lot of our
institutional shareholders showed to us
during that big financial crisis is
testament to the fact that we had done a
good job of communicating to them who we
were what we were trying to accomplish
and most of them did not cash out they
just said you know what we we know
you're going to bounce back this is
these are macro environmental events
beyond your control don't don't lose
faith and stay the course you also I
mean shifted some of your product
offerings and whatnot to have a wider
range of riding I mean because we do two
things during the financial crisis one
is that we recognize people were much
more value conscious
everybody was hunkering down we didn't
know if we were going into a depression
or not and so everybody stopped spending
the whole retail sector
I just Whole Foods virtually everyone
except for maybe Walmart saw a decline
in sales so we had to put value front
and center and that's actually been good
for us we had not taken it as seriously
perhaps as we should and we started
taking it seriously and that was that's
really helped us as we as the economy
began recover secondly we decided you
know what we need to besides working on
the value side of things and our pricing
we also need to continue to
differentiate how do we create space
between us and our competitors if they
can copy us and then sell it at cheaper
price we're not in a good competitive
situation we can match their prices on
things that are the same and innovate in
ways that we create products they don't
have then we've got the best of both
worlds what is the the basic route of
that discovery process for innovation is
that coming from you know is it that
people not associated with Whole Foods
come to you and say hey here's something
really cool is it regional parts of the
company coming up you know this seems to
be doing well here I mean all of the
above all of the above sometimes it's
your put suppliers
sometimes it's innovations that occur at
a store level that work like when we I
think I tell the story in the book about
this storm Santa Rosa California -
opened up a tap room bar which when I
first heard about it I thought that's a
bad idea I mean a bar in a grocery store
and he's going to go to a supermarket
for a bar I mean but it turned out to be
hugely successful so the point is the
store was empowered to do the experiment
if it failed they wouldn't have been
punished we would have just reallocated
the capital but they didn't fail they
were hugely successful now I think last
count we had 85 bars now across the
company not again
and commanded by Austin but simply by
storz imitating what they first saw and
improving upon it what are the external
forces I mean so you've got your kind of
pyramid of conscious capitalism what are
the X what are the forces that are
external to that whether it's the
government whether it is you know global
economic shifts you know that what are
the what are the toughest hurdles that
you're facing that are not within your
pyramid I mean obviously the most
difficult challenge Whole Foods faces is
every business faces is that we don't we
don't have any patents we're a retail
company so anything we do our
competitors can study it copy it and
they generally do study it and copy it
we're very innovative and then they just
try to sell it cheaper so this forces us
a to be pay attention to price but also
to continue to innovate so we continue
to innovate quicker than they can
imitate but it's their particular you
know regulatory issues that you're
facing or government issues where I mean
the government in a way is a stakeholder
but it's also it's a stakeholder that is
in the body of an 800-pound gorilla you
know where you're there's not much
dialogue and going on necessarily is
that an issue
well we face a lot of government
regulations in all levels from local to
state to federal depending on what we're
talking about you've got lots of
regulations regarding the number of
hours you can employ people I mean like
let's take California for example which
is consistently rated the worst place to
do business in America which I has been
my experience is true
you can't even used to be in most states
you don't hit over time for example
until somebody works more than 40 hours
in a week in California you hit overtime
when somebody works more than eight
hours in one day so you couldn't have a
flexible shift where somebody says I
only want to work four days a week I
want to work ten hours a day you know
we'd be paying for 32 hours a regular
time in eight hours of overtime a time
and a half so of course we're not going
to allow that to occur but the team
member might want that it might work
better with their life and we might want
that too but we're not allowed to
because the government regulations
really prevent it or penalize you
severely if you do it are those old
old-style kind of regulatory regimes are
they
aiding or are they just the cost of
doing business where even though you're
guaranteeing higher you know higher
level cleanliness or treatment of the
products that you're producing you know
you just got to deal with that because
they're not going away they're not going
away and they can be extremely difficult
let's take what claims you can make in
your meat department you generally have
to get permission we had to get
permission from the government before we
did our animal welfare rating program we
couldn't just say we've created this
system we're going to rate animals on
their wellness and here's what we're
doing though the government had to sign
off on all of our language and
everything we said we had to get
permission before we did it I went level
the federal government or federal
government of Agriculture has a division
dedicated to meat claims so we weren't
allowed to make any claims that they
hadn't approved up which means the
government can approve it that means
they can also change their mind right
and we're fortunate so far they haven't
but they could do you have a sense I
mean there seems to be a vast amount of
uncertainty in the you know regulatory
world in the economic world and in the
global marketplace is that level of
uncertainty and it's it's you know we
haven't even had a federal budget in
years I mean does this is this something
that is really weighs on you or is that
just something that you don't you can't
spend time worrying about it doesn't
weigh on us in terms of the business
because we can't do anything about it I
mean we're very concerned about a lot of
the health care there they're going to
raise the cost of coverage for employers
that system they already have what will
be your response to that
do you take if the increase in health
care goes up do you take it out of
people's wages do you hire fewer people
do you raise prices and hope to make up
the difference I think initially what
will happen not just for Whole Foods but
for virtually every company out there
that's got more than 50 employees they
give you an escape clause which is if
they work less than 30 hours you don't
have to insure them you're going to see
a lot of people working 29 hours
and Whole Foods is very proud of the
fact that 75% of our team members work
full-time more than 30 hours a week and
we cover them for health insurance but
if they keep driving the cost of
insurance up and our competitors are
going more and more part-time if we're
going to compete we may be forced to do
something very similar ourselves which
wouldn't be in the interest of our team
members our customers or our investors
none of our stake holders but of course
the government comes in and says well
now we're going to make it twenty hours
a week at that point health insurance
will keep gaining in terms of the pool
of money available to pay wages and
benefits health insurance will keep
gaining at the expense of the other ones
so your wages overtime will be less and
so if you like President Obama wants to
keep increasing the minimum wage
I won't affect Whole Foods we pay better
than that but what if you raise the
minimum wage for some companies and or
forcing health insurance on it
inevitably that creates more
unemployment as they seek labor-saving
devices for example that or they
reorganize themselves to not have the
labor more self-service or you automate
certain things to ends up increasing
unemployment as we know we know this
happens you raise the minimum wage and
you youth unemployment goes up it's just
inevitable well I talked a little bit
about the larger forces that are you
know that work against conscious
capitalism kind of developing as quickly
as you might want it to I mean I think
the biggest
kind of macro thing that prevents it is
just basic skepticism that people have a
belief that oh this sounds all very good
but in the real world where you're where
it's tough competition this isn't going
to work
now we think that's a myth but there's
kind of a you're kind of a macho culture
out there in the business world that
says you know only the paranoid survive
a nice guys finish last you know when
the going gets tough the tough get going
you're slots of your co-author in
particular has written books about
companies that are that flourish as good
places to work I mean that are clearly
part of this well let's end it with you
know one of the let's why I think
conscious capitalism Nick is ultimately
going to spread and if it if it doesn't
work better if it ultimately doesn't
create more value for investors and for
other stakeholders you know I'm just
I've written a very interesting book
that won't have any legs to it right I
don't think that's the case I really do
think these ideas are going to triumph
over the long term because they're going
to be adopted by young entrepreneurs and
their NSO and they're going to succeed
in the marketplace and the businesses
that are more conscious are going to
out-compete the less conscious
businesses over time and if I'm wrong
about that then these ideas want to
mount anything I don't think I'm wrong
though it I mean it's interesting
throughout the book and throughout your
work practice I mean there's a sense of
where these diametrical opposition that
we take for granted management versus
labor you know work versus pleasure etc
I mean they all seem to be kind of
collapsing and you talk in the book
about how Millennials for instance don't
necessarily think of work as something
that you suffer through but rather it's
part of the purpose of life so that you
I mean we'll see this in you know we
seem to see this in entrepreneurs among
younger people to begin with yes I mean
one of the things we emphasize in the
book that sometimes it's key idea but
hard for people to grasp we talk about
different kinds of intelligences and the
type of intelligence that were trained
in school which many people never master
the basic analytical intelligence the
kind of intelligence that our IQ test
measure which allows us to compare and
contrast and that type of intelligence
generally thinks in terms of trade-offs
they're always asking well how do you
balance this if you do this isn't there
trade-off there that's really the
analytical mind that's the way it sees
things it carves things up into its
parts in the conscious business where
you need a high analytical intelligence
you also need what we call systems
intelligence the ability to see the
whole system to be able to see the
relationships that exist between all
these parts so in the conscious business
doesn't think so much in terms of
trade-offs it's looking for innovative
solutions that avoid the trade-offs and
create these win-win win-win scenarios
and that ends up being very very
effective in business competition well
let's end with I'd like to hear you
comment a bit on one of the lines that I
thought was particularly memorable in
the book where you talk about life you
know life in business and whatnot it's a
the journey is joyful but not easy you
know what are you getting at with that
I've been following my heart since I was
19 years old and creating Whole Foods
has been the most fun thing I've ever
done except when I was talking to
lawyers back in 2008 it's been a lot of
fun because it's creative I mean I've
been being able to be highly creative
kind of in a flow state for most of my
career and you're you're a writer you're
creative type and so you know that when
you're creating life is kind of at its
peak Sparkle well business being an
entrepreneur as a form of creativity
you're creating something you're
watching it grow you're watching it
evolve that's fundamentally joyful right
even even when you're facing
difficulties it could be bankruptcy it
could be legal proceedings just failure
you can be joyful in pursuing what
you're I mean it's not every instant of
your life as joyful but you have more
joy than you have pain
but no it's it's like what I'm told I'll
never experience this myself but
apparently childbirth extremely painful
for women but they seem to also have a
lot of joy in it and they have a lot of
joy in raising their children so is it
worth it only each individual has to
decide that for themselves there is a
great deal of joy in being an
entrepreneur building a business there's
also some pain
there's also risk and there's sometimes
failure and that just company their
package deal kind of like life well
we'll leave it there thank you John
Mackey we've been talking with John
Mackey the co CEO and co-founder of
Whole Foods and the co-author of
conscious capitalism liberating the
heroic spirit of business which you
co-wrote with Raj Sisodia John thanks
very much thanks Nick
you